[Music]
today I woke up wanting to make the best
damn burger in the world okay maybe not
the best hamburger in the pan Dicky best
the burger but I want to make something
that generally hits the standard of what
an amazing burger should be now I'm a
Korean American specifically a immigrant
korean-american now in my household
growing up my mom was a bomb-ass chef
and she always made bomb-ass Korean food
but I got to tell you something I always
on occasion craved that delicious white
devil delicacy now what I say I want to
create a delicious burger I'm not
talking about adding truffles and all
this other expensive [ __ ] because
nobody got it like that good let's be
honest and let's well go into some fancy
ass restaurant if you're making this at
home I don't think it should cost you an
arm and a leg I'm looking to keep it
real simple aside from a few twists of
my own but I'm talking about beef
patties buns onions pickles tomatoes
lettuce cheese and all that other good
stuff now if I want to make a delicious
burger I have to eat a delicious burger
so when it comes to an affordable
delicious burger I think nothing beats
in and out I'm a Cali boy so we're not
gonna go into this whole argument about
what's better Shake Shack or in and out
I just know that in and outs of my [ __ ]
can I get a double double animal style
with chopped chilies and then there'll
be it no friend rates ago to go please
thank you yes there's this huge debate
on what burger is better right the Shake
Shack burger the in-n-out burger and let
me tell you something real quick
we are working within the parameters of
this being affordable and delicious now
Shake Shack is delicious and arguably
sometimes I got to say when I crave a
Shake Shack burger
I wanted over in an out burger but we're
talking about affordability this [ __ ]
right here is cheap it's look homey so
if you've never had it in an uppper girl
let me just break this down for you
about why this burger is so great so we
have two soft griddled buns we have pick
tomatoes - delicious pieces of American
cheese because I got it as a
double-double and then we got these
caramelized onions in between that and I
got to say [ __ ] heaven definitely
when it comes to a Shake Shack burger
their buns are really special they use
potato rolls this is just that classic
white bread bun but I love it I mean
come on yeah it's worth it okay welcome
to the [ __ ] kitchen homies so
we just had an intern a burger and I
told you the reason why I'm basing this
stuff off of it in an out burger man my
face is greasy so let's talk about a few
of the ingredients that I'm going to be
using in the burger that I want to make
the best damn burger on earth you know
what I'm saying [ __ ] moon crescent
king first up let's talk about the bud
now I see it in your damn squinty little
red eyes and you're gonna go for the big
button you're gonna go for the bun
that's like the brioche bun the pretzel
bun but I'm advising you not to do that
number one we're trying to keep this
cheap but you just need a classic
regular white but like I said they're
cheap but because they're little pockety
and airy when you griddle these or when
you put it on your cast iron or whatever
pan that you're gonna put it on that
heats gonna permeate through and you're
not gonna have to heat the other side of
this now remember be mindful of your bun
size okay not slider small but you know
these regular tiny little buns I don't
want too much bread I want to taste the
meat and the cheese and all that other
good stuff you're gonna need some
goddamn lettuce the type of lettuce that
I like to use butter lettuce I like
butter lettuce because it's just it's
soft it's not so bitter but it still has
that nice crunch and I love that leafy
green look that it has next up of course
we're gonna have tomatoes now for me I
love tomatoes in my burger specifically
because it adds that nice acidity of
freshness that I think a really heavy
burger
NEADS if you don't like tomatoes in your
burgers you could omit this out also
nobody loves you these are beefsteak
tomatoes these are huge all you need is
one good slice for these particular buns
before you put these in the burger
they'll make sure you salted a little
bit that's my little trick you can use
roma tomatoes I think Shake Shack use
roma tomatoes but me beefsteak all the
way
next up now I know I talked about
tomatoes adding acidity and freshness
well guess what that's but also the
pickles are going to do I [ __ ] love
pickles in my burgers I think it's a
very necessary component and of course
to that we are going to also add to the
Blau some banana peppers sliced banana
peppers also known maybe as
pepperoncinis now let's talk about the
sauce my friends this special sauce this
right here
shada bad attention without a doubt now
what makes this aw special the sauce is
just basically I say roughly about 60 to
70 percent Japanese kewpie mayo and the
the 40 to 30 percent ketchup ratio and
then with that you add pickle relish to
that last but not least we have
caramelized onions I love caramelized
onions if you don't want to put this in
this burger that's okay that's a
preference thing but I'm telling you my
friends delicious as hell last but not
least we got the booth what type of beef
regular old ground beef we're talking
about 80/20 most likely Chuck if you go
to any grocery store you can find 80/20
ground beef 80/20 just means that is 80%
meat 20% back if you want to get your
organic whatever beef [ __ ] or you want
to make your own I don't know special
blend like Shake Shack does go ahead and
[ __ ] buying doing that [ __ ] [ __ ]
looks like I almost forgot American
cheese baby and let me tell you
something real quick you are not allowed
to substitute anything with American
cheese you want to put cheddar Gouda and
all that other fancy stuff this is
American burger you put a French cheese
on this you might as well go to George
Washington's grave and piss in his mouth
talking about that American cheese homie
now say cut you know let's get the
cooking [ __ ] well hello you sexy
mofos let's talk about how to assemble
this burger by doing this binging with
Bobby's [ __ ] now before you start
cooking your burger make sure that you
prep your ingredients caramelize your
onions slice your tomatoes clean your
get everything nice and ready before we
add that meat to that pen now when I
make my patties for this burger I
actually don't form my patties before I
put it into the cast-iron pan now I know
for a lot of people they're like what
are you talking about you might you know
smash all the juices out you need to
press that burger like it's a deadbeat
daddy that owes you money because we are
looking for maximum brownness and we're
looking for that nice crust on each side
before we flip it and we of course add
our delicious American cheese after you
add your cheese make sure that you take
one patty you stack it on the other
lift it up take it out and let that meat
rest because we're cooking it till it's
nice and pink turn off the heat and if
you have a cast-iron pan the residual
heat should be enough to toast your buns
now before I put the buns into this pan
I made sure to lather it was just a
little bit of kewpie mail it's going to
be way better than butter my friends you
won't miss the butter when you're
toasting these buns when it's nice and
brown take it out the pen and let's get
ready to assemble Oh we now first up
homeboy you already know what we gonna
do we gonna add that delicious sauce to
that delicious toasted bun now after all
that we of course are going to add that
delicious sliced tomato because it's
gonna add the freshness that we need now
after the tomatoes we of course are
gonna go for those deliciously sliced
dill pickles and like I said before we
are going to need the dill pickles to
slice through all that fat that we're
gonna have from those ground beef
patties and cheese now at this point I
decide to leave out the banana peppers
because I just [ __ ] forgotten that's
some real [ __ ] people all make mistakes
move on next up we have that delicious
tender butter lettuce if it's too big
cut it in half and just stack the
remainder parts with the nice pretty
part now we got the main stage mofo we
got those two delicious beef burger
patties that are nice and rested in pink
in the middle with those delicious
pieces of melted American cheese now we
cannot forget those delicious low and
slow caramelized onions that you put so
much love and time into because my
friends this is a necessary part to what
makes this burger so damn delicious
now if you like sauce like I do take the
other bun spread that extra sauce onto
it and then stack it on top and there
you have it my friends the best damn
burger your ever quite to eat and here
we have it my friends yes
this right here is
oh look at that look at that juice just
drip from it my friend that drip drip
[Music]
I'm not saying I made a burger that's
better than in a number ger but I'm
saying that look at the inside I get to
make it to my doneness and just toasting
it with that QP mail just makes a world
of difference having the burger cooked
to medium salting of tomato all the way
through those grilled onions and once
again the QP Mayo special sauce that I
made mmm oh my god mmm
something about a burger man I don't
know what it is but you don't know the
kid like I said I grew up eating amazing
Korean food but nothing ever just
replaces of really good burgers I see a
lot of people who add you know crazy
fillings to their burgers like dad you
know bread crumbs and eggs their burger
patties don't do that that's a meatloaf
we want to taste the beef
[Music]
hmm go out there my friends make this
burger I [ __ ] you not this burger is
better than in and out and Shake Shack
combined it's like Shake Shack and and
now had a baby we talk about the quality
of the products whatever the potato bun
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] maybe I like it
because I made it but I'm telling you
guys right now
amazing Oh y'all whoa that concludes
this video if you like to see more
content or if you want to see me make
some other type of food leave it in the
comments below on top of that I'll just
be making a lot more videos now you guys
already know as before with the other
video I stopped doing JK news and I just
got more time now to focus on this
channel aside from doing the thrillers
episode so yeah man check it out a like
comment subscribe all that other good
stuff and I will see you guys next time
ship a boom boom boom boom take the [ __ ]
out right here no no I'm not gonna do it
okay
well maybe not the best hamburger in the
world but I wanted to make a burger that
what the [ __ ] am I saying